das desaster hat einen namen dass der
name ist jens spahn dass der jetzige
gesundheitsminister ich muss ehrlich
gesagt ich war schon ein bisschen
angefasst als damals das losging
impfzentren zu schließen direkt in die
reiserückkehrer welle rein und jetzt
dieses liefert desaster also das für uns
ist es eine katastrophe eine katastrophe
aber wie wütend
ich bin sehr wütend richtig wütend weil
natürlich jetzt eine situation wo
endlich die menschen sich impfen lassen
sie stehen in schlangen bei unserem im
zentrum sie stehen schlange an der
hauptwache unserem zentralen platz die
impfplan die fährt über weil die
menschen sich impfen lassen da haben wir
doch die ganze zeit für gekämpft da
waren die plakataktion dafür die
kampagnen der bundesregierung unsere
städtische kampagne jetzt ist es endlich
erreicht selbst die im skeptiker herr
aiwanger lässt sich impfen frau
weigel die afg prinzessin hat auch
crooner gehabt da gibt es keine
diskussion mehr fake news oder ähnliches
endlich wollen die menschen sich impfen
lassen wir sind am ziel und genau der
situation geht an der impfstoff aus das
ist wirklich chaos pur und das ist
richtig schlecht organisiert